all right I started a new I started a
new feed I'm gonna put it into the chat
here alright check for it in the track
guys this is the new feed sorry about
that
ok alright we can do this all right
April April is the what is the month of
things not going right that's pretty
much what April is all right so if I can
ask the mods Jacob and I think Brad is
there so just maybe post into the other
into the other stream to post the link
once in a while just to get everybody to
to change rooms
alright ok here we go
yes yes the beard has been cut yeah I
told you April is a crazy 8th April is a
month of madness in so many ways so I
hope everybody is doing what they can is
doing OK in the world of quarantine of
isolation of
whatever it is you have to do Lisa
you're supposed to be sleeping what are
you doing here that's what I was told
was gonna happen um man I don't know
what to tell you guys it has been it has
been absolute madness first of all the
first thing I want to do as people kind
of as people kind of pour in here is I
want to I just want to thank everybody
they supported me seriously you know
when when the quarantine hit and
everybody was everything was shutting
down in the entire world you know I was
fully braced to see people the support
that I was getting go down I was like
you know this is gonna happen it's it
you got to get used to it you know this
is this is normal with everything that's
going on and I have to say that I have
seen some people kind of you know move
on and to all those people that have
moved on I have to say I hope you know
I'd say God bless you I hope I hope
you're doing okay I hope you were
finding opportunities and that this has
not been a too crazy a time for you and
strangely enough I have seen all the
sudden all these other people kind of
come up and and support me as well so so
it's just been really touching to see
people to see people kind of stand by
what I'm doing you know I've been seeing
my views kind of dropped off on YouTube
I've been watching you know my videos
taper off like they would take off and
then a day later taper off and it's hard
not to think that that I'm not in
YouTube's best I might uh be might be
just that my my content isn't the best
content right now but um anyways I'm
doing what I can so I want to thank
everybody for being there I hope those
that are Orthodox I want to say Christ
is risen it's hard to think to say that
I've spent the last two pastas at home I
have not had Easter in two years last
year almost
- on the 27th of last year my house was
flooded on Easter Saturday and so I was
not able to go to - Easter and then this
year we all stood at home in our in our
house looking at zoom video watching
people trying to sing at the same time
on zoom not totally understanding that
you can't have many people singing at
the same time is kind of a strange chaos
but it was still there was still a
little bit of paska I guess you know but
at the end of the the Easter service
this year my Bishop Bishop Pierre Rene
said this is the strangest Easter it's
the strangest pasta he has ever seen
so still we need to - to stay in the
spirit of the risen Lord and I hope that
Christ is bringing everybody bringing
everybody a sense of peace and and trust
that God is in control no matter what we
see and no matter how insane the world
seems to be going right now so so yeah
alright guys so I let's go into the
question so also I have to say another
thing before I get into the questions
for those who have been waiting for a
April patron only video it is coming I
recorded it today really by the skin of
my teeth I just I just I would sit in
front of the camera and I just couldn't
talk for the last few days I've had I've
had some very very difficult news of one
of the my favorite people in the world a
member of my family someone who I love
who is young has been diagnosed with
stage 4 cancer and you know I just I'm
just struggling - just struggling to get
past that and so and so anyways but I
was able to record it and I will try to
put it up tomorrow
so all right so let's get into the
question guys all right so I am starting
with
website so as you know people who give
at the $10 level have early access to
questions and so I will go through those
questions I I try to do one question for
person guys just because there's a lot
and so once we're done with that we'll
see if if there's stuff that comes up in
the Super chats so here we go so Josh
the mover asks hi Jonathan do you know
of any words from the biblical languages
that refer explicitly to things like
patterns or fractals are there church
fathers who spoke about patterned
reality explicitly or have the patterns
always been an implicit structure within
the teachings thank you I would say that
in the Bible what we see is we mostly
see the patterns being enacted whereas
in the church fathers you and so it's
not like that it talks about patterns
but rather that it shows you the
patterns and it enacts the patterns in
it enacts the pattern in a narrative but
when you look at the church fathers that
you do they don't use the word fractals
because fractals it's surprisingly not
fractal the explicit use of the concept
of fractal is a very modern I don't know
when it started but it's a very modern
mathematics it's a very modern science
you would say although fractals have
always existed and if it existed in art
and patterns and all kinds of places the
the reference to it back to fractals
explicitly as well as the you know the
Mandelbrot fractals and all these
mathematical formulas are modern
discoveries modern developments and it
goes to show too how you know as the
world advances one of the things we see
is that as it sometimes loses the
implicit or the the higher understanding
it's developing the explicit
understanding and so we are worse we're
still still seeing amazing things come
up as we move further in time we're
seeing you know
there's all these things there's all
these things in Scripture that talks
about like in the end times you know
we're going to see some surprises and
there's the idea that we're gonna find
that animals that used to be extinct are
going to reappear again and the one of
the things that I think is part of that
is also the reappearance of the of texts
like the reappearance of the Book of
Enoch of all these books that were
basically lost to most people I think is
part of this this strange kind of
gathering of everything together as you
know as we approach the eschaton
whenever that's gonna be maybe it's
still very far away who knows but oh I'm
sorry but in the church I'm gonna be
like these guys I'm sorry I might I
might not be super super efficient here
but in in Sanger benissa he actually
uses the word archetype and he talks
about pattern so for example in the life
of Moses there is this idea that as
Moses ascends the mountain when he gets
to the top he receives from God the
pattern of the tabernacle and the
pattern of the tabernacle is basically
the pattern of reality and it's the
pattern of Christ its Christ himself and
so Christ is the pattern of reality
integrity or Misa and and of course he
doesn't use the word fractal but Steger
Bernice himself engages in a kind of
fractal structure as he talks about the
the mountain of paradise being a cosmic
mountain but then also being the
tabernacle and also being the human
person and so he's always working at the
dip on the different levels at the same
time of the same pattern alright and so
Benjamin r-va says Jonathan I'm
struggling to reconcile Commandments and
traditional values like honoring one's
parents when those family members
themselves are deracinated from and in
some cases hostile to traditional
patterns of being how should I commune
with a family that is out of communion I
suppose this is a microcosm of how to
love people in the world as it is now at
the
core level the Benedict option of
withdrawing from corruption feels right
at the family level less so any thoughts
yeah it's tough it's tough you know I
think that there's this there are these
there are these two ballot there's this
balance we see in Scripture you know
when there's this idea that we need to
honor our father and our mother we need
to honor that which is our origin
because that is by which we get our
identity so and so we need to enact the
on we need to enact at a lower level the
let's say the worship that we give to
God because he is our ultimate origin we
need to reenact that at a smaller scale
and at a smaller level to the things
that are our own origin and our are that
are the source of our legitimacy and so
our parents the the king
you know our authorities all of these
things you know all power comes from God
as st. Paul talks about all authority
comes from God but it does it is
possible for that order to become
corrupt it is possible for our parents
to be bad parents and you know and I
think that in that moment we can see
where we can see where there are other
statements about Christ you know about
really radical statements that Christ
makes about you know if you do not hate
your your brother or your or your father
your mother if you know if you if you
don't that do not hate their even their
family will not know cannot come into
Christ and so there's this idea that we
also need to get things in the proper
hierarchy that is if your family is not
in line with what God is asking then you
need to you need to give honor to that
which deserves honor but then also not
give honor to those things that don't do
that don't deserve honor
you can honor your parents and your
honor your father and your mother for
having given birth to you for having
raised you for having giving you a name
for all these things but you do not have
to honor them in the ways in which they
are deviant from what God is asking you
know and so I think that that's probably
the best way to look at it and I know
it's it's tough it's difficult to do
that but as you become an adult and you
find your own space especially and you
kind of find your own life it's probably
easier to to do that where you know you
you don't have to be arrogant and
disrespectful and hostile to your
parents but you also don't have to honor
them in the things which don't deserve
honor that's how I see it but I know
that these things are difficult in the
practice so I don't want to make it
sound like it's easy so new my ask why
does Christian II find it unnecessary to
follow certain laws from the Old
Testament I usually hear that it is
something with the destruction of the
temple which I get in terms of fee
sacrifices and other things having to do
with the temple I don't quite understand
that in terms of the Sabbath and
sabbatical years are not eating the
fruit of a tree for the first three
years and other things not necessarily
pertaining to the temple perhaps it has
something to do with the law being more
than the individual Commandments given
either way I'm clueless so this is a
really good question and it's not a it's
not a super easy question to answer
because in a certain manner you would
almost have to look at all the laws and
each law and kind of look at why some
laws are followed and why some laws
aren't there is a sense in Christianity
that the law has been resolved has been
let's say has been brought together in
Christ and so all the laws of the Old
Testament find their resolution in the
person of Christ and so that has an
effect on the law so for example one of
the so for example one of the things
that I often tell people is
the the the law about not making graven
images for example is resolved in Christ
because Christ is the image of God and
so we are given an image and so in that
way the resolution of the law happens in
the person of Christ and it actually
kind of flips the law because we are
given an image and then in that image we
celebrate the image that God has given
us and we accelerate the fact that we
all participate in that image by that by
becoming the children of the new Adam so
that's a way in which the law is still
there it's not gone but it has it's kind
of brought into Christ there are there
are other laws example the Sabbath where
we also understand it to a certain
extent the death of Christ as the
resolution of the Sabbath and so we see
if you look at the Paschal if you look
at the Paschal hymns you have this whole
sense that that the day that Christ is
in the tomb is the the true Sabbath that
it is the resolution of the Sabbath for
example right that it is the all the the
holy Sabbath and as Christians we are
asked to live in the eighth day in the
the bringing together of the end in the
beginning the day of the resurrection at
the day after the cycle but which is
also the beginning of a new eternal
cycle and so and so it's not as it's not
that the Sabbath isn't there anymore
it's that it has been brought into
Christ and so you see that in a lot of
the different laws now I'm not going to
go into all the different laws some of
the more technical laws those that are
more to do with kind of ritual purity
and all these things are also not
followed as much because we are not Jews
we are the strangers we are the we are
the impure that have been brought into
Christ and made pure through Christ and
so we are not asked to be circumcised
right we
after participate in the circumcision
rituals and so those circumcision
rituals have all I call them
circumcision rituals but you could just
call them rituals of purity the idea of
not mixing different things the idea of
you know or the idea that you can't eat
certain food that certain foods are
impure you know you have this this
moment in the the Acts of the Apostles
where Saint Peter is dreaming and he
sees the cloth sees this cloth come from
the heavens and it unfolds in front of
him and on the cloth is all kinds of
pure and impure meats and he hears the
voice which says eat and st. Peter says
I can't eat that food I I'm a Jew I've
always followed the law I can't I can't
eat these impure meats and he hears
again you know it happened again he has
a vision I think three times and by the
third time he decides to eat and that
becomes an image of how now the
outsiders the the those who are not
Jewish are meant to come together into
the same space as the the Jews and so
that also imply that we are allowed to
eat also different meats that we don't
have to eat that just the meats that are
kosher for example so that is usually
the argument which is given in or in
terms of the law but the law is still
very useful it's very useful to study
the law it is very useful to understand
the different laws I always like to go
into the strangest laws and try to show
how they are extremely meaningful and
how they actually point towards Christ
so I hope that that answers that
question
all right so David flora says have you
considered doing live stream carving
drawing sessions would be cool to your
art come to life as it to see your art
come to life as it happened well I've
thought about it but um it's not a very
technical person I just can't imagine
setting up a camera in my workshop and
and like even right now I don't I don't
even have the Internet
my workshop because it's at my house
which is still which we I still live in
and there's no internet there and so so
I probably would work but maybe one day
who knows it's possible
so Kenan Cronin asked if you could give
one piece of advice to all fellow
Christians what would it be I mean I
would say that if I could give one bit
of advice that I would say to to see
that Christ is everything that Christ is
is that the in Christ you find all the
keys to the all that all the keys to the
questions of a reality so Djoser 7:33
asks hello Jonathan could you give an
interpretation of Tobit going blind via
bird excrement man to be honest I've
never thought about that I've never
really I've never really pondered that
question I would have to think about it
I would have to think about it I mean I
would say it like at first glance just
like this I would say that it probably
has something to do with the mat the way
that Saint Paul became blind something
about being blinded by heaven but I I
would need to I'm gonna need to think
about it more and get back to you
alright so C Mon Sigma C Mary had two
different levels of reality and so st.
George represents the killing of the
dragon of st. George has something to do
with at the earthly level it has
something to do with the individual
level in terms of the this in terms of
slaying our our demons in terms of
fighting our passions all of that kind
of stuff
there there also has to do with the
enemy there's also an image and I know a
lot of people feel uncomfortable with
that but it also is an image of a nation
or a city or a state which is able to
subjugate an enemy which is bleeding
them dry
there's also it is also an image of that
and and that's why a lot of people don't
like the icon of st. George but the
image of st. Michael then that is really
the cosmic image of the saint pattern it
is really cosmic image of of the heavens
pinning down the chaotic potential you
know that is below you no stopping it
from its destructive its destructive
capacity and every time you have a an
image let's say in scripture I don't
think it's talked about him being
speared but the image of spearing a
dragon is really important because
there's something about pinning it down
which is more than just killing it right
something about you know the chaotic
waters you can imagine like a snake
that's it's kind of moving in the water
then you pin it down you know and you
fix it and you stop it from being the
stop it from being subversive and
chaotic right you it's also this is yeah
yeah and it's also this is also the idea
of pinning down the serpent is it this
is gonna is also related to putting the
bronze serpent onto the pole and it is
also related to Christ being nailed to a
cross
you know when Christ is nailed to the
cross one of the things he's doing is is
becoming the serpent that is fixed to
the to the space becoming time which is
being fixed to space that is also
happening in the crucifixion all right
all right guys so I'm gonna I'm gonna go
on like I told you I'm gonna do one
question for a person who asks oh if
your second question gets skipped guys
sorry about that
I am going to now go into subscribe star
all right so Nikola asks what is the
interplay of femininity and masculinity
and Mary the mother of God
she is the most holy of all saints hence
higher than all the church fathers in
terms of heavenly hierarchy but it is my
understanding that feminine is
subordinate to masculine in some way
she's clearly feminine in her
relationship to Christ but what about
her relationship to everyone else and so
this is something that I've talked about
a few times
Nicola the I the way of understanding
and the idea is to understand that you
can have you you can understand it as
masculine feminine it has a basic heaven
and earth right so above and below but
you that pattern and this is when we
talk about fractal patterns that pattern
reproduces itself at all the different
levels of the hierarchy and so at each
level the hierarchy is composed of a
masculine and feminine aspect so a
little heaven and a little earth is that
every level of of the ontological
hierarchy and idea at the at every level
of the fractal structure reality okay so
you could subdivide the all the
different levels of reality into other
different levels and then again in that
you also have this reproduction of this
of this of this pattern and so and so
the mother of God is so so for example
if you think about the primordial heaven
and prime world your earth a way to
understand it is to understand heaven
and earth as this primordial opposite
and then everything in between but
another way to understand it is to also
understand the primordial heaven and the
primary look primordial earth as as
above everything else and so the mother
of God
she is feminine but she is the highest
feminine she is the cosmic feminine you
could say and so she is above us and she
is higher than us on the hierarchy and
there is a version of the of the higher
of something above you in the hierarchy
which is feminine and if you have a
mother you should understand that your
mother was feminine and was also above
you on the hierarchy the way that that
the masculine and feminine will so you
could say that that would that which is
feminine above you in the hierarchy you
could say to a certain extent that it
plays a relatively masculine role in
regards to you and so for example a
queen is you know has an authority
similar to a king on your life but there
will still be a distinction in the way
in which those are enacted you know
they'll still be a distinction between
the manner in which a king acts and a
manner in which is Queen acts you know
so hopefully that is and and you know we
haven't careful like it we have to also
be careful not to think that there isn't
an aspect of the feminine which is you
know not which that the feminine can't
be a kind of tyrant or can't be a you
know a an extremely authoritarian figure
of course of course that can happen
there is you know every everybody has
experienced not everybody but several
people will have experienced that in
their own life with a teacher or with
their own parents you know the
tyrannical
feminine figure is quite quite possible
and it really comes about you know it
comes about my brother in material
always talks about how when you when you
start with symbolism you need to kind of
master the basic categories right you
know and and that's totally fine and you
you need to do it you need to master but
as you continue to dive in you see how
you know then you start to see the
subtleties you start to see how how it's
it's actually very in its simplicity it
it there's a subtlety which
which sets itself up you know and it a
good way of understanding it is like a
very good wine is that you you you start
to discover the the savers and the
flavors so sometimes when I try to talk
to guys I always I try to talk in a way
that is understandable but there is as
you dive in you start to see how these
things interplay with each other all
right so hopefully that answers that all
right and so Christian Chad our man asks
hi Jonathan
what effect do you think Machiavelli had
on the ideas of leadership and
Christianity can we ever reach the idea
of a good just king in a world of
Machiavellian and politics also the last
videos were brilliant very good content
keep it up um I mean I think that
Machiavelli was I think Machiavelli was
pointing out something which was already
there and it's not like Machiavelli
made-up Machiavellian politics I think
that he was he was making explicit
something which was already there you
know the difficulty of earthly power the
difficulty of earthly hierarchies and so
can we ever reach the idea of a good
just king you know I think it's possible
I think it's possible I think it's
difficult and you see that in all of
history you see it in Scripture it's
like how many good Kings were there in
the Bible really you know and how many
good leaders were there in the Bible and
it's the same in history you know a lot
of people complain about the about
Christianity about about Byzantine
emperors or popes and how corrupt and
horrible they are and the thing is is
that most of the time it's not
necessarily false it's not false the
problem is when you think that that you
can do better or that you can decry the
authority and then try to replace it the
I think they're real the Christian way
to do it is to decry the authority but
then not trying to replace it and you
see that in you know for example figures
like Saint John Chrysostom
whoo-hooo denounces the king for his
immorality and then is killed you see it
at the same you know with people and
same acts with the confessor who see
that the emperor is wrong in their
position and he denounces the emperor
but he doesn't try to take political
power and remove the authority and so
that is the reality we live in and so I
believe that it is it is completely
acceptable to criticize the authorities
and remain submitted to them that I
think is the Christian way a lot of
people will disagree with me I'm sure a
bunch of Americans will disagree with me
but I'm Canadian and I have a queen so
you know all right
okay so XRD asks hi Jonathan are you
familiar with Camille Paglia and any of
her writings if so what's your general
opinion of it as an artist sexual
persona really spoke to me I think she
before Peterson was the person that
prepared me for thinking like yourself
well I haven't read a lot of paglia I've
read some I did a talk based on her on
her thinking I did a talk called sacred
art in secular terms where I used one of
her papers to show the importance on the
necessity of something like sacred art
and that even someone like her is able
to see it I think that Camille Paglia
like Jordan Peterson it's someone that
has kind of come out on the other side
that is especially coming upon me it's
like she's gone through the 60s she went
through the whole counterculture thing
she went through everything and now it's
like she's come to the other side where
she realizes that that if you
be countercultural right now the the
only way to do it really is to encourage
is to encourage something that looks
like tradition and I don't know if she
would agree with me and I don't know if
she would see it that way but it seems
like that's what she's doing maybe
despite herself and she seems to to be
sometimes advocating for a kind of
traditional position even if she's doing
it because she wishes she had had
something to repel against because
that's the problem right now is that
there's nothing to repel against I mean
in terms of for all those that wanted to
break the taboos like what taboos are
left really
I know taboos left so alright and so
next question
Samuel asks hey Jonathan hope you're
well
have you been listening to anything
interesting recently I got a lot of free
time to expand my mind at the moment
take care the eyes I have not been
listening to a lot of stuff recently I
usually listen to a lot of podcasts and
a lot of things when I'm in the workshop
and I'm working then I tend to listen to
stuff but when I'm you know recently
we're working on the blog I was writing
an article by the way for those who know
Bishop Barron's work I am publishing an
article in his magazine in June so in
the word on fire in June I will be
having an article which talks about
movies and narrative the importance of
living inside a narrative and also to a
certain extent I will also talk about my
differences with Jordan Peterson so if
you are part of that group I hope they
make it public and they put on the
website but I don't know if they will
they might not but sorry Sango right now
I'm not listening to much all right so
let's let's move on I am going to go
to patreon and that's usually where we
have the most so yeah we are the most
questions and you know what I'm gonna do
I'm going to take something to drink
because so so pasca so the passable
season still in flair so cheers
everybody there are all these like that
when I go to the US every year and I go
to Charleston I just really got into all
these sour beers that everybody's making
but here in Quebec they're just not
making these sour beers and so finally
in Quebec it's starting to hit and so
I've been having some some interesting
sour beers in the past past little while
they even they even put out there's a
company they even put out like a nice
salty sour beer which is really nice all
right here we go guys into patreon
all right so Dom Palermo asks greeting
Jonathan my question is regarding the
relevance of bodily integrity for the
Christian considering an an individual
Christian feeling divided facing the
question of submission to secular
authority to take a compulsory shot
under the skin given the spirit field
st. Paul explicitly calls Christians to
be in submission to civil authorities
while it is also true that the early
church defied civil orders when meeting
in the catacombs meant maintaining their
identity by gathering at the body of
Christ given where I called to be holy
lived by faith and to be obedient to
Christ what else might we consider in
this dilemma is the maintaining is
maintaining the integrity of the body in
context of secular 3 an important value
for the quick for the Christian all
right so you guys are bringing me into
you guys are bringing me into the into
the dark the dark question so yes we are
called to submit to authority as
Christians we are called to submit to
authority to the extent that the
authority does not ask us something
which is contrary to to our submission
to Christ right we we the the Christians
were asked to sacrifice to the to the
Roman Emperor or to burn incense for the
Roman Emperor and they refused to do
that and some of them were killed
because of that some of them were burned
at the stake
you know burned at the stake for that
the stake man that was weird
no they were they were killed in the
killed in the arena mostly but the
question of what's going on right now
with the idea of a mandatory vaccine I
think that we need to be very attentive
to Jimmy it's not it's not as much the
question of bodily integrity and like my
fear has been really talking to me about
this recently and he it it's been
preoccupied him quite a bit to the
extent that he almost accepted to make a
new video with me because he's been so
preoccupied by that you know the both
both himself and both him himself and
myself we've talked about the question
of the vaccine in our in our writings in
our videos about how it's an image of
death turned against death and how it's
an image of using death in order to
fight off death and so we have
emphasized the positive aspect of the
vaccine but it is not only positive
there is also a negative aspect to
vaccines you know because it is taking
death into yourself there is a negative
aspect to it it can be a negative aspect
to it now it's not so much the question
of bodily integrity which is a problem I
think for us right now I think the the
question that the the question we have
right now is rather the question of the
question of control and the question of
the problem that is happening is mostly
the problem 666 that when I talk about
in my in my in my different videos it's
the problem of trying to account for
everything and trying to account for the
margin or using the margin to account
for everything
using the exception to cap to account
for everything we talked about that in
terms of the weird situation of the
Apple CEO you know of these kind of
weird hate speech laws and the way that
they try to to have all the marginal
identities be included you know to a
point where someone who just wants to be
having integrity in that way bodily
integrity could be an image of it the
only person that is excluded is the one
who wants to maintain integrity and
those that are there those are the ones
the only ones that are being excluded
and so anybody who wants to hold on to
any identity like any normal identity is
is dangerous of being pushed out whereas
all the marginal stuff is being brought
in and so the vaccine can also be an
image of that as well especially if it
is tied to control and especially if it
is tied to identification you know and
so if if there is a vaccine which you if
there is this idea that you have you are
given a vaccine and buy this vaccine you
are included in society and without the
vaccine you are excluded from society I
think that that's the place where
Christians have to really really wonder
whether or not this is this is the right
thing to do and whether or not this is
this is really approaching
sick sick sick symbolism in a manner
that is that's - that's too hot to
handle so take it for what it is guys I
don't know what's gonna happen so when
things start to play out you know maybe
I will have to - to be more explicit
about that but for now I would say just
be attentive you know nobody is nobody
is forcing us to do anything for now
that in terms of our bodily integrity so
we just need to be attentive and keep
talking about it so all right all right
so Dionysus asks hello Jonathan
why is God the Father and the Holy
Spirit inconsistently represented or
emitted completely in the icon of the
Last Judgement if the fathers included
it sometimes
I sometimes see his hand above Christ
while in other icons appears under this
it appears under the scale the Holy
Spirit is sometimes with the scale but
usually absent why is that
well Dionysus the reason the reason why
that is is because the whole idea for
example of representing God the Father
is is problematic we have images of the
Trinity for example the baptism image
and there are some iconographer 's for
example who will who refuse to represent
the Holy Spirit as a dove outside of the
outside of the icon of the of the
baptism of Christ because the Holy
Spirit is not incarnated as a dove the
Holy Spirit appeared as a dove and and
so it's a it's a contentious question in
iconography the appearance of God the
Father is also very contentious so you
will find icons with God the Father
fully represented especially in later
Russian icons you will find God the
Father represented full-on as a bearded
old man you know about Christ or next to
Christ
that happened a lot of people talk about
that how Orthodox I'd became more
Western had more Western influence
because until until like the 14th
century I would say 15th century 16th
century it starts to creep in at the
around the 14th century but before that
they really weren't any representations
of God the Father there are
representations of Christ as the Ancient
of Days and then that image of Christ as
the Ancient of Days slowly got morphed
into an image of God the Father but I
would say most Orthodox today don't
represent God the Father fully um and so
yes it is possible to represent the hand
of God and it is possible to represent
thee to represent the Holy Spirit as a
dove sometimes some like I said some
iconography don't feel don't feel
comfortable with that and so that is why
you will probably see that it's not
systematic and you can make an icon of
the Last Judgement which is not
necessarily invoking the Trinity you
know just like you can make you know
because the Last Judgement at its basis
is is its its Christ who who does the
Last Judgement and so if you look at
earlier image or simply images of the
Last Judgement it's just you know like I
said this image from from Rome is it
from Noah
yes it is from Rome from st. Mary major
where you have Christ and you have the
sheep and the goats on each side you
know and so that is a very simple image
of the Last Judgement you can have an
image of the Last Judgement which is
just Christ in glory and then you can
have more complicated images whether
there's it's flat where you you are two
tiers and then you get it more and more
elaborate elaborate elaborate ins and
you can see how in some images they
might have wanted to include Trinitarian
reference but it's not it's not
necessary the elements of the of the
Last Judgement icon are variable you
know it's like you can have it's not
that they're variable in the sense that
you can put in whatever you want they're
variable in the sense that you can have
can have minimal virgins and maximal
versions right so images that contain
all the different elements and then you
can compress it down to just a few
elements if you need to that's a better
way to understand it it's kind of like
I've talked about in some talk recently
that to a certain extent the image of
Christ contains all of iconography in it
you know and so in the icon of crisis
although iconography and all the types
and all the saints and all the different
feasts are is that so as if you take the
icon of Christ and you unfold it and you
take out parts and you show us parts of
that of that icon so so so it would be
the same with the Last Judgement I would
think all right all right so
Christopher's cetera ass hello Jonathan
I am interested in Christianity on
artistic literary and philosophical
levels I am fascinated by Christianity
but so far have not been compelled to
become Christian on anything more than
in Jordan Peterson level I read
Christian works in the same manner I
read secular works
are there any California Buddhist asked
dangers of engaging with Christianity in
this manner well I don't know I don't
think I don't think it's the same at all
as the California Buddhist because if my
under scriptura cetera I imagine that
you are not from another like you're not
from India or from China or from from a
country that is in traditional Christian
you're probably your ancestors were
Christian for the past fifteen hundred
years or whatever and so it's not as if
you are just yeah it's not as if you're
fascinated by by the appeal of something
strange and and glittering which you
don't understand it's more that you want
to rediscover your roots and you want to
rediscover that which your ancestors
have given you you know and so I don't
think it's the same I would say that
just I would say that you don't have to
force anything I would say continue your
interest continue to read continue to to
engage with Christian ideas I would say
ultimately it probably a good
here for you to to participate in a
Christian service to to attend liturgy
to participate in liturgy that sometimes
can be more existentially attractive
than just reading and so to be in a
service and to actively engage or to to
to to be part of of something um
it's different from just reading so I
would say that if you're wondering about
that I would say just try to drop into a
church once in a while and participate
in the service because Christianity
isn't just in the head it there's also
if you're interested in the artistic
literary ideas liturgy music is also
part of its space architecture all of
these things so I would say to engage
with that and just you know just take it
one step at a time and see where it
leads you alright so Jorge Fernandez
asks or is this a question not sure he
says hi Jonathan I've been reading the
book of Romans and I was shocked by Paul
this blew my mind
Romans 8:35 239 who shall separate us
from the love of Christ shall
tribulation or distress or persecution
or famine or nakedness or danger or
sword as it is written for your sake we
are being killed all the day long we are
regarded this sheet to be slaughtered no
and all these things we are more than
conquerors through him who loved us for
I'm sure that neither death nor life nor
Angels nor rulers nor things present nor
things to come nor powers nor height nor
depth nor anything else in all creation
will be able to separate us from the
love of God in Christ Jesus our Lord
III I also get chills every time I read
that so what do you think of the
symbolism of this message thank you I
mean that's it that is that symbolism
right there that's that's what symbolism
is symbolism is that we exist by the
love of God and Christ that is that is
how the world exists and so nothing can
separate us from the
of God because it is the very manner by
which we exist it is the glue that holds
the words world together and the and
Christ has the incarnation that's the
point where heaven and earth meet is the
the fulcrum is the turning point is the
axe axle of everything and so with and
so we cannot be separated from that you
know we it is our very breath it is that
by which we exist all right so Christian
Pennington asked hey Jonathan I'm a
longtime viewer but first-time
questioner I recently done a little bit
of research into Lilith and the story
surrounding her could you give a brief
overview of her symbolic role and how
that may be relevant to today thanks for
all that you do may the Lord continue to
bless the work of your hands all right
so I think I've talked about this before
first thing to say is that Lilith is not
it's not Christian it's not a Christian
story it's a Jewish it's a Jewish legend
it's a Jewish story and so you won't
find talk of Lilith and it's in the
church fathers but I do think that
nonetheless I think that there is
something to ponder there are some
things you can understand in the story
of little it's just like there are some
things you can understand in a lot of
extra biblical stories or extra you know
or stories from other cultures are from
other from other mythologies the the
idea of Lilith and what she means has to
do with that which was before the origin
and I've talked about this before this
is really a structure of social reality
which is that the you know I usually
talk about space and I talk about the
idea of you have a center and a center
of identity and then you
you have a hierarchy and then on the
edge of the hierarchy then you have the
borders and then you have a kind of
mixture hybrids and then you have chaos
on the outside okay and that chaos is
full of monsters and Giants and and you
know all these all these demons and all
this stuff right all this dark stuff on
the outside okay so you can understand
it that way
but you can also understand it as in
time and so you can also understand that
you have an origin in time which defines
you something that starts you okay so so
the origin of your country the founding
of your country the founding founding of
anything right and so when you have a
founding everything which is based on
that founding is coherent right it's
connected to the founding it has its
origin in that beginning and so because
of that it lays itself out coherent lis
in it and it has meaning and it's
logical it flows from the origin okay
something like that but all that was
there before the origin is not connected
to the origin right to a certain extent
it is it is the potential out of which
the origin has food like it it's that
which feeds now the new origin and the
new origin can reshape restructure we
you know reorganize some of the stuff
that they take from before and then put
it forth in a in a coherent manner okay
but that which is before the origin is
its chaos its chaos and it's dangerous
it that's why that's why that's why all
the neo-pagans are that's why new
paganism is being used to destroy
Christianity that's why Egyptian stuff
is being used to destroy Christianity
that's why you know the the more obscure
the less
known the better the Minoans you know
these these the snake print these snake
goddesses or they weren't probably
different goddesses but these snake
dancers are all these like strange
residues from ancient ancient ancient
cultures they are used to to destroy
that which they are elements of chaos
that are used to to bash the the origin
of the world and so that's what lilith
represents lilith is is the wife before
eve if the wife before the wife that
Adam had before humanity existed right
and so if you want to understand what
that means in terms of story it means
that she is the one who gave birth to
all the monsters she's the one who gains
gives birth to all the Giants to all the
you know and and you see the same story
in the in the story of the gods it's
saying the Greek god the pantheon before
the Olympians you have that's that's
where you have all the Titans and all
the monsters and all these these these
monstrous Giants with thousands of arms
or whatever the the the Giants fighting
the Titans and all this crazy stuff that
happens before the Olympian gods is
because they're before they don't
connect to the origin they appear as
monsters and they are monsters for all
intents and purposes because there is no
you don't have and you can't abstract
yourself from from your world they are
monsters and so Lilith's children are
the monsters they're the demons that you
know the especially the monsters that
are the bouncers and kind of demons that
are related to to to sexuality you know
in the West they did it did kind of
merge with with Christianity the idea of
the succubi and incubi being the
offspring of of lilith once again it
makes sense you know that you have to
understand it as
I hate when it gets into this stuff
because I always feel like it's it's
it's the reigning of my talk just keeps
getting higher it's like it okay so
there's rated pg-13 that's rated R so
where are we going here but so so
imagine for example the idea of the idea
of a succubus right
the idea of a non-consensual it's a
relationship with a demon and you can
understand it as a nightly emission if
you want it so your seed is being spread
out in unconsciousness not in not in the
conscious world not through your will
through something else through some
other mechanism is being taken from you
and that is that is a it's monstrous
it's it's a dream it's the dream world
it's that it's a chaotic world it's the
world that where things don't make sense
where things transform into the other
you know and so that's what that's what
Lilith and all this kind of stuff is is
also referring to on a on an individual
level but they're not just individual
levels of this there's also social and
cosmic levels of these kinds of things
alright guys like I said don't don't
it's like if you're Orthodox this is not
stuff you tell you don't talk about
Lilith to your kids because it's not
part of that it's not part of our
tradition it's something it's something
which is kind of on the outside like I
said you can think about it it's it can
be useful but it's not it's not kosher
in the Christian Way it's kosher because
it's Jewish but it's not uh you know
what I mean all right here we go
so Jason Lindsey at hey Jonathan
alright in your brother's book he uses
Abraham as an example of a proper
hosting of angels that lead to the birth
of Isaac as a counterexample to this to
this as a counter to this example he
uses the story of Manoah and his wife as
an improper hosting of an angel that
leads to the birth of Sam
looking through both of the stories I
don't seem to find what exactly Manoah
and his wife did wrong Manoa does not
seem to recognize that the angel is one
of God at first but eventually he does
so I presume that alone is significant
enough to lead to the downfall of their
son
in addition is there significance that
Samson is not compared to or identified
as a Nephilim
despite his similarities to them the
product of an improper relationship with
angels raw power and strength etc thank
you for any insight into the story your
videos on symbolism and principalities
finally broke the last barrier that was
keeping me back from grasping what a lot
of these old stories we're talking about
well thank you Jason that's very kind of
you
so first thing I can say to chasten is
you're looking in the right places if
you want to know if you want to know
where the the let's say the deepest
nuggets are in my brother's book they're
always in the footnotes and so in the
book my tear in a footnote talks about
how you know it and his wife improperly
hosted angels now I think that you one
of the things you maybe didn't get right
is that he doesn't say that they did
something wrong that's not really the
point he says that they were not
accepted as proper hosts because what
happens is Manoa offers food to the
angel but the angel refuses the food you
know and this is the difference between
Manoa and Abraham is that but excuse me
by giving by giving food to the Angels
in the story of Abraham he hosts angels
he becomes the proper host for angels
and that is what brings about his son
now in this story when he offers to give
food to the angel the angels refused and
the angel says you should offer give
your offering up to the Lord's or take
the food and then offering up to the law
as they are offering up the food up to
the Lord the angel disappears into the
flame and goes up and so it has
something to do with you know I talked
about this idea of the bird which comes
down and picks something you know the
the predator bird which comes down and
picks something up you know and there's
something of that happening in that
story it's like the angel is is not it's
like you can imagine like the the feet
of the angels are not let to touch the
ground that the angel comes down but
doesn't touch the ground there's a
separation which remains and the angel
is taken up and that is what makes
Samson into more body than spirit you
know Samson is more body than than
spirit you could say and so when you ask
your questions like that you compare it
to the Nephilim you're right you're
totally right
this is this is this is the the right
questions to be asking there are there
are some church fathers that talk about
how Samson is one of the closest to
Christ and there's also the biggest
question is the biggest question is
asking why is Christ not seen like a
Nephilim that's the biggest question
it's like Samson as well Samson is like
a prefiguration of Christ because he's
also he's bringing things together and
he's doing it in an improper way and so
that's why he's not he's not Christ of
course but he's bringing things together
and it's kind of awkward you know he he
takes the door you know he takes the
door of the city and brings it up to the
top of the mountain you know he takes
the margin brings it up to the top of
the mountain you know when I talk about
things like the crown of thorns where I
talk about this type of imagery that
Christ engages with this is something
that you see in the story of Samson he
he marries the foreign woman you know
just
Christ marries or you know gives the
image give this story of him marrying
the Samaritan woman and in in his story
and also Samson he he he finds the honey
in the impure right he he finds wisdom
in the dead carcass of the lion and so
right that is Christianity that's what
Christianity is Christianity is finding
the fish in the the fish in the deep is
finding wisdom in these dead you know
foreign nations that is what
Christianity is it so Sampson comes
really close and so in a way there is a
something of a relationship with
something like the the Nephilim in to a
certain extent and so once you
understand that that's one of the
problems being posed you can also
understand all the fourth century of
Christianity you need this is the key to
the 4th century if you want to
understand why the Church Fathers just
fought so much to talk about the nature
of Christ and that the fact that he is
fully man fully God two natures you know
under unmixed fully United fully
separated without being mixed you know
all this type of language where they
want to show that Christ has two natures
which are fully United in his person but
are not confused that is them trying to
help us understand why Christ is not a
is not a giant why Christ is not the
mixture of heaven and earth it's not the
mixture
he's the full complete union which
preserves also that separateness at the
same time that's the difference between
synthesis and confusion and this is
something seriously the difference
between synthesis and confusion if
people could just understand that right
now the difference between between
synthesis and confusion so much so much
of our problems
would would fly apart like we just
vanished
when you see someone who talks about
Christ as being the first you know kind
of transsexual person because he he
transcends a male and female
he joins them together in his person
that's that that is not seeing the
difference between transcendence and
confusion or synthesis and confusion all
right here we go
so Vanessa asks what are the symbolism
of the addiction people develop with
tattoos piercings and plastic surgery
once they start it seems to change
people's judgments about their
appearance and they can't stop adding or
fixing do you think it's just a common
disorder or linked to a greater pattern
I mean I think that for sure there's
something to do with our with a passion
you know all our passions can take tape
because not everybody is addicted to
that you know some people get a tattoo
and then that's hip some people got a
piercing and that's it but there are
people that get into it extremely and I
think it's probably no different from
any passion you know the thing that
would lead you to get a tattoo sorry for
those who have tattoos but usually it
would be some kind of a passion of some
kind you know and the same with
piercings it's like an easier for vanity
it is ear to a desire for vanity a
desire to to to appear in front of
what's you to stand out you know for
your strangeness or whatever but you
know just like someone can can have a
beer and then another person becomes an
alcoholic I think it's it's no different
I think it's just a passion you know
someone becoming possessed by a passion
and then being completely taken over all
right so sander Cooper kut'r asks is it
Satan as accuser the gap but
between being and doing an actual eyes
potential then the compliment of Christ
crowned by meta time is Satan bound by
meta space bound by the logic of
remaining potential not sure I totally
understand your question sander but what
I do see let's say in terms of when you
said Satan bound by meta space I would
wonder if that has there there is an
image of Satan bound in Christianity and
you see that in the icon of the icon of
the resurrection the icon of the descent
into Hades sometimes you see Satan and
Hades being bound by angels are just
being bound under the the feet of Christ
but I'm not track totally understanding
what you mean
alright so norm gonna ask you speak
often of Christ flipping things around
or enacting an inversion such as the
crown of thorns turning death into glory
would this be part of Christ as master
of unity and multiplicity are trying to
bring everything back together yes
that's what I think it is I think it
really is trying to bring everything
back together and this is the mystery of
non-duality you know the idea that if we
believe that the world at that we
ultimately reality that God is non-dual
ultimately and that there and that
everything is good that everything is
good if it is in its proper place and if
it is in its proper direction if it is
directed properly and if it is in its
proper place and everything is good
there's nothing that is in itself bad
evil is always a a improper attribution
of something in the wrong place in the
wrong direction it's okay
that is that'd so my contention has
really been that that death and glory is
made of the same stuff you could say
that that which was glory became death
and that which is death can be changed
into glory and so that solves the
problem of death and it's really hard to
think about this but it you know there's
something there's something interesting
you know when you look at sorry about
all the new pagans you who are watching
this I keep going after you guys you
know just because it's just the thing
that's on the horizon right now I can
see these neo-pagans kind of coming in
the in the in the distance so so for
example one of the accusations that the
new pagans have of Christianity is that
it's it's somehow fetishizes death right
that it's weakness because we we accept
death and that their metaphysics their
vision of reality is is strength
you know it's boldness it's this kind of
will will over the world all of this
type of attitude but see the problem is
that you're gonna die that's the problem
is that you're all gonna die so so how
do you deal with that you have to deal
with death and if you only see death as
a tragic undoing of all that you built
if you only see death as a tragic as a
sad tragic end to a life of strength and
will and imposing yourself on the world
then you lose you lose that's how
reality ends the reality and that you
lose until what Christianity does is
that it says we're gonna deal with death
we're gonna take it seriously dude do
you you're gonna die
so what is death what is it why is it
part of reality or what what can it do
what can it do for us and that and that
you find the Christian answer which is
that in the Willing acceptance of death
you transcend yourself and and that
death is transformed into something more
right so yeah that's how I see it all
right let's keep going
all right so Herman Smith says hello
Jonathan Christ is risen indeed He is
risen
I knew so I apologize if this has been
asked for I'm noticing an interesting
pattern for initiates initiates into
orthodoxy and the exorcism we spit send
out water of our bodies of Satan and
baptism we are submerged in water that
has been blessed at consummation we are
sealed with oil which does not mix with
water so that we are essentially
waterproof keeping the symbolism of
water as death chaos am I seeing this in
the right way yeah I would say that
you're seeing part of it you're seeing
half of it I talked about this before
that there's two there's two there are
two waters there's a water above there's
a water below in the in in Scripture at
the beginning of Genesis God separates
the waters so at first there's the earth
is this it's watery and then he
separates the waters there's the waters
which goes above the heavens and then
there's this water which is below and so
you can understand it as a as a kind of
potentiality and I always talk about how
the margin
goes low and goes high at the same time
this is also the related to the death
and glory problem which is that that
death goes lower but it also brings you
higher and the waters go lower but they
also go higher and so in this in in our
tradition in the symbolism you have the
water below which usually represents
exactly what you said which usually
represents death a kind of cleansing of
death but there's also water which comes
from above and that is usually seen as a
blessing it's a water which comes from
above in terms of in terms of blessing
you know when they they they sprinkle
blessing blessed water rain and also in
for example in Catholic baptism they
they tend to emphasize mostly the the
idea of water from above and so they
they they take the water bring it up and
then pour down on the person you know
they make that gesture bring the water
up and then Britain and pouring it down
and in orthodoxy we have that a little
bit not as much the idea that you has to
be its moat it's supposed to be active
water it's supposed to be moving water
and so you know like some priests will
will make a wave even in the in the the
baptismal font to have this kind of
moving water depends on the different
things and so you really have these two
poles so it's not just death and chaos
but it's also kind of higher potential
you could say or something which that
which is above which comes down as water
so hopefully that helps and it just
maybe it just confuse you more
it's also possible okay so an Joe
terpstra asks you have talked frequently
on the vessel that's container the ark
Noah the ark in the tabernacle it seems
to highlight the vessel as a place of
protection in order to prevent
amalgamation with the outside but it
might also be a place of transformation
this is highlighted in young
psychological interpretation of medieval
alchemical symbols typically these
manuscripts were
portray a vessel between polarities the
Sun and the moon according to young the
health fire underneath the vessel will
get will give rise to a new symbol which
functions as a balanced answer between
the polarity I was wondering if there is
Christian symbolism on the vessel
transformation and polarity I've noticed
that Christ on the cross is frequently
portrayed with the Sun and the moon but
maybe this means something completely
different
well for sure in terms of Christ on the
cross it's not it's it's not just that
he represents Sun that which is between
polarities he also represents the origin
of duality and the origin of everything
and so you're right that in a way you
will see Christ represent on the cross
and having the two sides the left on the
right hand the Sun and the moon the good
and the bad thief you have these
different sides and Christ is in the
center and represents the axis of the
world that which which is then separated
into two and so he joins the whole world
together it brings everything together
and he is the origin of everything at
the same time now in terms of the vessel
as the place of transformation I mean I
think that that is not strange and you
know in terms of the idea of the womb in
terms of the idea of the earth you know
as the place of of life and of change in
all of this you know and that the earth
as a vessel you could say is the
mediation is the place where the
influence of the opposites are being
played out you know and so I don't I
don't find that odd at all I don't think
it's weird I mean I don't know it's
probably not phrased in the same way
that you all would phrase it but I think
that it's definitely it's definitely
there
and I don't know enough about chemical
symbolism to be honest to be able to
comment on the other part alright so
mark Peters asks a general social
observation about past fashions is that
they come back to later generations as
something new but they don't all come
back at least
not to the general public and conversely
something seems come seem completely
bizarre and novel such as young men
wearing big pants 12 inches below their
waistline
what is this symbolic meaning of this
and I wonder if anyone has ever done a
study on the return of fashions and how
these fashion statements map onto the
social dynamics of period thanks I don't
know I don't know in terms of in terms
of how they map onto social dynamics
there's probably something there it
seems that one of the reasons why
fashions are being recycled especially
today there's something also about
nostalgia in the in the way that
fashions are being recycled because the
idea is that we do function with
patterns we do we do function with with
cycles we we all that's how it works you
know days months years our world is made
of cycles and so I think that fashion in
the past was often confused with
progress you know this idea that these
new things that come about they're just
an image of progress but I think that by
now we've actually kind of seen or
especially with post-modernism maybe
we've also accepted the reality which is
that they cycle and that there there's
this cycle we've accepted it in a way
that is also feeding the market and so
one of the things that we're seeing is
that fashions are coming back to the
children of the parents and so for
example like when I was a teenager all
of a sudden we were we were all wearing
you know 70s stuff bell-bottoms and we
we go try to hunt for all this old stuff
and so now my kids you know my 12 year
old girl is wearing weird stuff from the
80s which I it's like you never thought
it would come back but you can see that
also in movies and culture where you
know
it's like I when I was a kid who played
with transformers and now when I became
an adult all of a sudden these
Transformers movies come out again same
with Marvel comics you know when we were
kids we would read Marvel Comics and
then as adults now our kids watch the
movies so it's like this weird cycle of
fashion where you know it's also to
maximize their profits so that I can
also enjoy the same thing as my kid is
enjoying but I mean it's it's just it's
it's inevitable that the world will
manifest itself in patterns that's for
sure
all right so so all of our Erikson asks
how good of an understanding of
symbolism do you feel like you have I
have watched you for about a year and I
feel I've only gotten started but you
haven't thinking this way a lot longer
how deep does it get I mean I don't I
don't I think he gets a lot deeper than
what I understand that's for sure I
think that I I have a certain level of
understanding but I can peek and I can
see that there's way more that the well
goes a lot deeper than what I can
perceive and so I don't know if I can
measure that but for sure I know that I
think that I think that in terms of my
own understanding of symbols I feel
always feeling the same like I'm just
starting you know and then I get hit
with some some insight or something
about a story that I'm it I didn't
notice you know so so yeah and it's fun
it's a it's a great road to be on so
welcome aboard
all right so Danny
asks are the waters in the creation
story the same as the waters from the
flood Noah
they are analogous they're not exactly
the same you can understand them at in
like a different level you can say that
the waters in creation story are like
the ultimate waters that cosmic waters
whereas the the story the the waters and
the the flood story are that they level
down in terms of their implication and
so but they are similar and they are
very similar because the
waters come from above and from below
and they join together right there's
rain and there's water coming from up
from below we always think just the rain
for some reason there's also water
coming from below and they join together
and they create this this chaos this
kind of return to primordial chaos and
so your insight is quite good um alright
so Lord Marduk Wow Lord Mar Duke is
asking me questions so a question about
the ending of the novel Loras and any
more thoughts you have on the novel and
how it compares to our current situation
spoiler alert okay at the end of the
novel they dragged his body through the
field after his tribute services I
imagine it was a way to heal the land
and the outsider observing it was a
stranger was a strange thing to do
observing it was a strange thing to do
is there a particular ritual in Russian
folk tales or religion that points to
dragging his body through the field
there is a plague during the time of the
novel it has to do that in this in the
lower story it really does have to do
with the the problem of the holy fool it
has to do with the problem of the the
person who wants to kind of evacuate
himself into the world and so the you
can understand that scene as it's a
desecration of his body he wants his
body to be desecrated and you would say
why would he want his body just
desecrated and this is where the
extremes need this is where this is at
least I think this is the desire to be
shown in them in the book this is where
the extremes meet this is where the
Christian martyr who is desecrated the
Christian martyrs are always desecrated
right their bodies that their bodies are
always are always are always desecrated
and that desecration ends up to their
glory it doesn't mean the desecration is
good most people should not
have their body desecrated most people
should be should be properly buried and
in the novel he talks about that problem
too because he he he cries because his
that this the lover he has at the
beginning of the book that she is is not
because she's not going to be properly
buried so he has this kind of anguish
about that at the beginning but that's
the the idea is that in his case at
least that's the way I understand it he
is going to the end of his father to his
holy fool persona and he is asking for
his body to be desecrated and that is to
his to his highest glory but it's it's
like I said it's dangerous stuff man
it's dangerous stuff because you you
have to be able to tell the difference
between what the holy fool does and a
masochist those two things are not the
same right a masochist
who who who wants to be humiliated for
his own pleasure is not the same as a
saint who is desecrated to his glory and
and I know that it's it's tricky because
we we see confusion about that in in
popular culture there is some confusion
about that but those two things are in a
way there are opposites they're not
they're just not the same at all so so
yeah so wow that was the that was the
last question guys and so I went and I
don't happen I don't know half is pretty
much like the time that I feel that they
should go if I can help it and so I
think I see that I in looking at the
chat I think that I I think that I
disable the super chat by starting this
new this new feed okay so now I see
some super chats are sent into the other
chat so let's look at those so sorry
about the chaos guys I didn't mean to I
didn't mean to / - it's so so some
people in the original chat put out some
super chats because I am starting in
this new stream I guess I didn't I
didn't know that I had to to put in some
some some I had to change the the pair
meters or whatever I don't know what I'm
doing you guys are seeing the limits of
my capacities constantly with these live
streams things alright ok so I'm the
inch go what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go into my own so I should see the super
chat here alright okay so I see a bunch
of super chats in in my thing alright so
okay so Brad Pitt is back with a super
chat and he asked not to catastrophize
but do you think Christians should
prepare for flip similar to the
anticipation for the end of the world
I've really only heard Roger talk about
this legitimately yeah there are fleets
happening all the time right now I think
anybody who's paying attention is
noticing how insane the political
narratives are becoming and how
conservatives are becoming are acting
like we used to think liberals are
acting liberals are acting the way we
used to think conservatives would act
and you know and so it's it's crazy even
when this whole penned anything it's
really hilarious and lot of people I
pointed out to it about how you know the
right-wing people are the ones who want
to open up everything and the left-wing
people are the ones who want to keep
everything closed down and want
everything did it to remain shut down
and so we need to really prepare not
only for the Flis but for a little while
it's not good it's going to be crazy
it's gonna be kind of like it's going to
be it's gonna look like a ping-pong
table we're gonna
see things flip back and forth there's
gonna be just madness you know I think I
told you guys that you need to get ready
for 2020 I didn't expect this to happen
but I knew that this year was going to
be mad it's not over man there's an
election in the US this year it's going
to be crazy this year is not done become
being insane
you're not done seeing madness this year
and we're also starting to see you know
once once a few times I joked I said I
never thought at the end of the world
would be so funny and and I always knew
even when I said that that it's not
going to be like that the whole time so
just get ready for the worst guys all
right here we go so common sense culture
ask I have a few years experience with
woodworking and I'm drawn to icon
carving I'm worth it off can you
recommend process timeline and learning
resources to get there um so I mean
there isn't an official way to do it you
know we have like I give workshops you
can also learn to paint icons just to
learn to draw that you need to learn to
draw and so if you can't draw you're
gonna struggle to be an iconographer so
you could take car icon painting classes
or icon drawing classes in order to to
kind of get drawing and you can practice
carving on the side like you can
practice probably and other things you
can take carving classes of other types
of Carbon classes that you can find in
your local you know in your local town
or whatever but learn to draw icons and
then slowly try to merge that together
and I always tell people like if you
send me pictures if you start carving
icons and you send me pictures by email
I will I will comment you know it might
take a few weeks before I answer an
email but I will I will I will answer it
you send me carving pictures so all
right so cabal for $10 says my prayers
go out to you and your family thank you
question other than being monsters and
on the edge
there any other relationship between the
Giants begotten by the Watchers and
Saint Christopher well yeah in the sense
that one of the things you can
understand st. Christopher as is the
ultimate possibility of the edge right
to understand how these aspects of the
world can be saved in Christ that's
really the idea now in terms of the
terms of the story of st. Christopher he
is he is its Ria's name - not through
his origin which is that he's in some of
the legends they say that he's a
Canaanite the fact that he's a he's a
Canaanite is is trying to link him
directly to the to the Giants like
through through genealogy to a certain
extent it's it it's a fantastical
genealogy but but by calling him a
Canaanite they are trying to link him to
the Giants that you know like Auggie and
all these giants that the Jews that the
Israelites encountered when they came
back to the promised land and those
those Giants are seen as remainders from
the flood in tradition so there is a
direct relationship in terms of what
people how people would have understood
Christopher to have been so Andrew
Johnson asked what is the meaning of the
young George Washington throwing a coin
across the Potomac River I and Ray I
have to tell you that as a Canadian I've
never heard that story so I don't even
know what it refers to I'm sorry you're
gonna get mad at me I would have to I
would have to to know what what it's
about George Washington coin
he threw a silver dollar across their
rap and knock River is it possible to
skip a coin or flat rock I have no idea
sorry dude I wish I could give you more
on that but I do not know so alright
guys I think I think I think we're done
I think we're done last one the roy
plank what are your thoughts on the
sacred secretion or the christ oil is
this New Age nonsense or do you think
the symbology can have meaningful fogs
oh Christ I don't know what that is
sacred secretion sacred secretion
I have never I don't never what is this
it seems when I look at when I look at
the the books that talk about this it
looks it looks pretty new agey to me but
I don't know what it is so I don't want
to speak out of turns there alright
everybody thank you for showing off once
again Christ is risen I wish you all you
know all the best in this today strange
time I would say as I always say just
pay attention keep paying attention to
what's going on don't let your don't let
your attention drop not right now
there's a lot of stuff going on and we
need to to to try to see what it is is
happening in terms of patterns and in
terms of how we can participate or
should not participate in the pattern so
I want to say thanks to my moderators as
usual all the folks that I like to see
in in the chat thanks for your work and
I will see you next month guys bye bye